gentleman to my right I'm a dancer on
Cox I'm an artist and producer on below
I'm Shawn loris I am a bad the audio
director copy Americans awesome awesome
and this is legendary
I've missed this game I wanted to know
what happened to this game it's glad we
got to see it come back so we're we're
we I know development how things been
progressing we are we're in the final
stages so we're wrapping everything up
we're polishing the heck out of
everything making sure that it's where
we want it to be planning all our bugs
as well just really kind of putting a
nice coat of sheet and ice clean this on
everything and really kind of tying
everything together and finishing
everything I'm sorry it's worked out
really well we've been leaving a glad
that we managed to do Forte without
without a lot of trouble whether it kind
of it worked out really nicely
especially with some of the art changes
that we've made it just kind of worked
really well so let's take a look it's
gonna do this game jumped by some off
but also living
what is the premise
what is what Steve don't
say an action/adventure
where you play a solitary
arriving at this island
it's nerdy to investigate this place we
basically tell you nothing
that's nila good simmer
the next step
your dead body neither things that you
found I think that you've done
you see
but you yourself had that character and
that
out of this world
and your head start
yes well in the lighting
the morning
in a peaceful but
means that our there be reactive and be
interesting and in have the light
get reimbursed
lp1 will press the hold
manipulate the light itself exactly
focusing point this clamp it's a
singular point of light that we have
the player has found on
and now that we found it
the next person that comes
that light's not happy
that is to persistence
for the team
so right now we're literally going we're
going down there
so check your lights super
like 20 sec tarnation
okay so exactly upper left corner
exactly that's where you're gonna be
able to see thirsty
kraspo
not just engage
what are you doing right now
[Music]
and very long
we don't do things like this we take
these opportunities
and make sure that that restoration is
his frustration uh I don't know how to
do
like we've definitely done a bunch of
that week please pass the audio yeah
where you needed to get two doors to
meet you you know in a ran to the area
can put
bro
water
so these are
the darkness
you get Japanese chips
right
there are
yeah
crap right now
we have
the world is persistent
if he catches the determination between
different
termination of
so in the same way an apartment building
this place is a big tourist wish but you
could always go
and neither florists
my hospital releases
we're going to be released in this year
2011 2018 that's good we've got dates in
mind
no matter what we're releasing the game
and we want a release and releasing the
game in the state that it needs to be in
absolutely and we got a we're still
feeling out
you know to get that email
back in Atlanta
well
below yeah in the building absolute
pleasure man thanks for coming by hey
thanks for coming by thank you thank you
good to meet you hello guys her eye on
it
you